large parts of california are
reinstating indoor mass mandates as
cases rise in the nation
michael george has the latest southern
california's orange county fair kicked
off with
rides food fun and crowds limited to 75
percent of normal capacity
amid the pandemic just to the north a
new los angeles county mandate requiring
vaccinated and unvaccinated people to
mask up indoors
takes effect this weekend but saying
it's not backed by
science la county sheriff alex
villanueva tweeted that his department
doesn't have the resources to enforce
the mandate
originally i felt like oh my gosh here
it is again
have to put this thing on her face for a
little bit longer but if
it saves one more life then i guess it's
worth it in northern california several
bay area counties have also issued new
mask recommendations
the moves come as every state across the
nation reports
rising covet 19 case numbers a
disturbing pattern fueled largely
by the more contagious delta variant the
vaccines are still
very very effective in preventing severe
disease
we've got to get people vaccinated these
are life-saving
interventions and two people familiar
with the situation
tell cbs news that three vaccinated
members of the texas house democratic
caucus
that traveled in protest to washington
d.c last week
have tested positive for kovitt 19 with
rapid tests the texas lawmakers came to
the nation's capitol
in hopes of blocking a republican-backed
voting rights bill in the state
legislature michael george cbs news
the cdc says unvaccinated americans are
driving the spike in cobit 19 cases
accounting for nearly all deaths
in almost all the new hospitalizations